[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN STEPHEN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Dan Stephen.
I work in the ads business.
So my team works with
developers and advertisers
to help grow their user base and
also their brands with Google.
Today I want to give you three
sort of takeaways on ways
that Google can help you grow
a long-term, sustainable gaming
business.
At its core, Google
is here to help
you take care of the
basics so that you
can focus on more of
the strategic objectives
around building a business.
So we want to help you
build a core user base.
We want to then help you
use your data to enhance
your strengths, the
strengths of your game,
but also optimize the weaknesses
that potentially are creating
lower engagement,
and then, ultimately,
grow the most valuable
user base in your game.
Let's start off.
We know that you did not
create this game to just let
it sit on the shelf.
So how do you build
a user base quickly?
Developers and
advertisers right now
are dealing with the
complexity caused
by having just so
much data created
by multiple channels for
acquisition, multiple screens,
and multiple devices for users.
So we understand this and
have been investing heavily
in our machine
learning capabilities
to remove this
complexity for you
and allow you to still
reach the right user
at the right time in the
most efficient way possible.
Google can help you get
the world playing your game
by reaching users in the
moments that matter really
effortlessly.
And last year, we launched
the Universal App campaign,
which is designed to help you
reach users across Google Play,
Search, YouTube, AdMob, and
our mobile Display Network.
It's really easy to set up.
You just need four
lines of text.
Upload your favorite
videos and images.
And then set a cost per install.
Google then takes care
of the rest for you,
delivering you the
best of both worlds--
time savings and a
growing user base.
So how does it work?
Using the simple inputs,
what Google's machine does
is start to identify types
of patterns and behaviors,
using ad creatives to
see what converts best
on what particular channel.
So if Google learns
that consumers
are more likely to install your
app after clicking on a YouTube
ad as opposed to an ad
in AdMob, then the system
and the campaign will start to
optimize for that performance.
So you'll start
getting more users
from YouTube or the
various different channels.
But getting installs
is just a start.
So for point two,
successful gaming companies
understand that unique
features of their titles
are very different for driving
revenue and engagement.
We know the stat--
I think everyone's heard
it-- that, you know,
that 3% of your users drive
the majority of your revenue.
So the most valuable
asset that you actually
have as a gaming business is
your player data, the insights
about what the most engaged
users love about your game,
like where did they come from?
What parts of the
game do they like?
What parts of the game
do they actually hate?
How often do they come back?
And how valuable
are they to you?
But how do you
know these answers?
And how do you surface it
up in a way that's easy?
You just heard about
Firebase Analytics.
And this is Google's
free analytics solution
that helps you easily
understand the engagement levels
in your game.
Why are users coming back?
And what actions are they
taking that eventually
lead to the most
desirable outcomes
for your particular
game, whether that's
an in-app purchase, or a
share on your social network,
levels beaten, records
broken, trophies won,
friends invited, et cetera?
Which brings me to
the third step--
using these insights, so
using your player insights
to put the game in the hands
of the users who are truly
going to love your game,
your most valuable users
who will drive revenue
growth for your business.
You want to get the world to
love your game, which is hard,
not only because users
are discovering apps
from a myriad of new channels,
but also your user base
is actually more diverse
than ever before.
Historically, app
marketing has all
been about demographic targeting
and look-alike audiences.
Because these were the
folks that we thought
were likely to love our game and
drive value for our business.
The goal now is still
the same, to find
users who are likely to take
a desired valuable action.
But you can now look directly
at their actions rather than
their attributes.
There's an easier way to find
the users that matter most now,
those that will open your
game and just keep playing it
forever, and drive real value.
You can now activate
your user insights
with the universal app campaigns
to drive engagement and value.
Universal app campaigns
can automatically
find valuable users
based on the actions that
matter most to you.
All you need to do
is tell the campaign
what valuable event you want
your users doing more of.
You don't need to
worry about who
to target, where to find
them, how to reach them,
what ad format is going to work
best for them, what to bid.
The machine can do
this second by second,
impression by impression,
optimizing on the fly itself
in real time.
You can define any
in-app action that
matters, from completing
an on-boarding tutorial,
to beating a level, to
sharing with their friends,
or to making a purchase.
It's really easy to
integrate in an in-app action
and your conversion
data into AdWords
through either Firebase, or
[? codelessly ?] through Google
Play, or any of the third-party
measurement providers.
So just wrapping up--
in summary, Google
really just wants
to help you remove the
complexities of marketing
and business development
so that you can seriously
focus on the things
that matter to you,
which is effective growth.
So we do this by helping you
grow your core user base.
We help you surface insight
so that you can continuously
iterate and improve.
And then we use
strong signals to let
Google's machine
learning find you
the best users for your game.
So thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]